Tag zusammen!
Jack Pop hier.
"Resident Evil" ist zurück,
nicht als neues Game oder als Film,
sondern als Serie auf Netflix.
Die bringt uns zurück
nach Raccoon City,
eine Stadt, die den Fans bekannt ist.
Denn dort bricht 1998
das gefährliche T-Virus aus.
Ein paar Tage später
sind die meisten Bewohner der Stadt
entweder tot
oder laufen
als blutrünstige Zombies umher.
Schuld daran ist ein Mega-Konzern,
der das Virus im Labor
künstlich hergestellt hat.
Wie realistisch ist das?
Kann man Viren nach Belieben
zusammenbasteln und verändern?
Könnte so ein Virus
Menschen in Zombies verwandeln?
Das finden wir nun
mit einer Virologin heraus.
Wer Resident Evil spielt,
kommt an einem Namen nicht vorbei:
Der Umbrella Corporation.
Das ist ein
multinationaler Megakonzern,
der dieses fiese T-Virus
durch viele Experimente entwickelte.
Mit dem Ziel, daraus genetisch
modifizierte Zombies zu erschaffen.
Wie z.B. den Tyrant.
"Die ultimative Lebensform: Tyrant."
"Es ist großartig."
Weil der Release des 1. Spiels
schon über 25 Jahre her ist,
haben wir heute
einen YouTuber mit dabei,
der unsere Erinnerungen auffrischt.
Wo kommt dieses Virus her?
Warum hat Umbrella versucht,
einen Zombiemutanten zu erschaffen?
Hey Jack.
Die Ursprungsvariante
namens Sonnentreppe
wurde in den 60er Jahren
von Umbrella Invest Afrika entdeckt.
Existiert hat es schon länger.
Beim Stamm der Ndipaya
wurde die Wirtspflanze
als heilig verehrt
und für Rituale benutzt.
Die vielversprechendsten Nachkommen
mussten sich einer Prüfung stellen
und die hochgiftige Pflanze
konsumieren.
Starb eine Person,
weil ihr Körper
das Virus nicht bekämpfen konnte,
galt sie als unwürdig.
Überlebte sie,
wurde sie mit übernatürlichen
Fähigkeiten gesegnet
und führte fortan den Stamm.
Da die Umbrealla Corporate
großes Potenzial
in dem Pflanzenvirus sah,
baute sie ein Labor.
Und entwickelte das T-Virus daraus.
Umbrella
hat das Virus bewusst modifiziert,
um es als Bio-Waffe maximal
ansteckend und tödlich zu machen.
Vielen Dank!
So einem Mega-Konzern
traut man einiges zu.
Würde das wirklich funktionieren?
Das klären wir jetzt.
Mit einer Frau vom Fach,
der Virologen Jasmin Fertey.
Jasmin arbeitet
am Fraunhofer Institut
für Zelltherapie und Immunologie
in Leipzig.
Mit ihrer Arbeitsgruppe
entwickelt sie Impfstoffe
gegen Infektionskrankheiten.
Das Beste ist,
sie ist auf Resident-Evil-Fan
und hat die Spiele selbst gezockt.
Ihre Lieblingswaffe
ist deshalb die Beretta.
Jasmin, schön dass du da bist.
- Schön, dass ich hier sein darf.
Du hast die Spiele gespielt.
Was waren deine Lieblingsmomente?
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Dieser Moment, wenn die Tür aufgeht
und du weißt nicht,
was dahinter ist.
Weil du nur die Frontalaufnahme
auf dich hattest.
Du hast nur gehört,
ob da was passiert.
Für ein Horror-Game unerlässlich.
Wie war das bei euch?
Was hat euch am meisten fasziniert?
Was ist euer Lieblingsteil?
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare!
Wir wollen schauen, ob es
ein T-Virus in Echt geben könnte.
Was müssen wir uns da anschauen?
Dazu müssen wir uns anschauen,
was Viren sind.
Viren sind keine Lebewesen.
Weil sie anders als andere Pathogene
wie Bakterien
keinen eigenen Stoffwechsel haben.
Die müssen immer
eine Wirtszelle befallen,
um deren Stoffwechsel zu kapern,
um sich vermehren zu können.
D. h. so ein Virus ist nicht
so eigenständig und intelligent,
wie man sich das vorstellt.
Bei Resident Evil
ist die Besonderheit,
dass das Virus
aus einer Pflanze kommt.
Das fand ich schwer vorstellbar.
Gibt es das in Echt?
Muss ich mir Sorgen machen,
wenn ich in kurzen Hosen
durch den Wald laufe?
Es gibt Pflanzenviren,
Viren, die nur Pflanzen befallen.
Der berühmteste Vertreter
ist das Tabakmosaikvirus.
Ist es realistisch, dass so ein Virus
von der Pflanze
auf den Menschen überspringt?
Von einer Pflanze
direkt auf den Menschen,
das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Weil eine Pflanze evolutionär
gesehen weit weg ist vom Menschen.
Was öfter vorkommt, ist das Viren
vom Tier auf Menschen überspringen.
Das nennt man dann eine Zoonose.
Das hat man auch bei Corona gesehen.
Was vermutlich auf dem Tiermarkt
auf den Menschen übersprang.
Aber sie müssen schon
etwas ähnlich sein.
Von Pflanze auf Mensch,
das funktioniert nicht.
Von einem anderen Säugetier
auf den Menschen, das schon eher.
Dann halten wir fest:
Wie es bei Resident Evil
dargestellt ist,
dass es aus der Sonnentreppe kommt,
ist es unrealistisch.
Da müsste Umbrella
ein anderes Ausgangsmaterial haben.
Doch schauen wir uns
die Eigenschaften des Virus an.
Denn Umbrella modifiziert es so,
dass es Menschen
in aggressive Zombies verwandelt.
Das macht das Virus,
indem es eine Sache kann,
die andere Viren nicht können.
"Das T-Virus
belebt tote Zellen wieder."
"Im Grunde erweckt es sie
wieder zum Leben."
Tote Zellen wiederbeleben?
Geht das?
Es gibt tatsächlich ein Beispiel,
wo Schweinegehirne
wiederbelebt wurden.
Forscher in der
Yale School of Medicin in New Haven
haben es geschafft,
Schweinhirnzellen mehrere Stunden
nach dem Tod wiederzubeleben.
Dass man sehen konnte,
dass Neuronen feuerten.
Dazu muss man aber sagen,
es hatte nichts mit Viren zu tun.
Die haben die Hirnzellen
in eine spezielle Nährlösung
gepackt.
Und dadurch
leben die sozusagen weiter.
Nicht ewig,
aber für ein paar Stunden.
Wir können zusammenfassen:
Dass ein Virus von einer Pflanze
auf den Menschen übergeht,
ist sehr unrealistisch.
Und tote Zellen
mit Viren wiederbeleben,
das geht auch nicht.
Dafür braucht man
spezielle Hilfsmittel.
Sorry Umbrella,
das müssen wir widerlegen.
Man muss ja nicht unbedingt
Tote wiederbeleben.
Ein Virus kann auch für viele
andere Arten gefährlich sein.
Deshalb müssen wir mehr
über den Plan von Umbrella wissen.
Was genau hat Umbrella
mit diesem Virus gemacht?
Nach der Entdeckung
des Ursprungsvirus
entwickelten die Gründer
es so weiter,
dass infizierte Menschen
zu Zombies werden.
Und später
zu sehr starken Monstern mutieren.
Sie wollten
eine wirksame Bio-Waffe erstellen
und hohe Profite erzielen.
"Die Umbrella Corporation
hat eine neue Waffe kreiert."
"Nur dass sie diesmal
eher biologisch als nuklear ist
und sehr gewinnbringend."
Nach mehreren Virus-Varianten,
die sich
aus den Experimenten ergaben,
setzte einer der Gründer
noch eins drauf.
Er fügte Blutegel-DNA hinzu
und erschuf daraus das T-Virus.
"Das T-Virus schafft Monster."
"Milliarden werden sterben."
*Sie schreit.*
Das klingt sehr verrückt.
Aber wir haben hier schon
eine ganze Menge gesehen.
Könnte das funktionieren?
Kann ich Blutegel-DNA
in ein Virus packen?
Prinzipiell kann man fremde
Erbinformation in ein Virus packen.
Aber nur in sehr begrenzter Weise.
Ein Virus besteht aus Erbinformation
- DNA oder RNA -
und einer Proteinhülle.
Viren haben sonst nicht viel.
Da kann man auch nicht
endlos viel hinzufügen.
Wenn du dir vorstellst,
das Genom eines Blutegels
hat ca. 200.000 Basenpaare.
Das Corona-Virus,
das ein großes RNA-Virus ist,
hat 30.000 Basenpaare.
Da kannst du dir vorstellen,
da kannst du nur
einen kleinen Teil einfügen.
Damit das noch funktioniert
und in die Hülle passt.
Und eine geschlossene Struktur hat.
Da sehen wir,
der Prozess wäre unfassbar aufwändig
oder mit solchen speziellen
Informationen nicht umsetzbar.
Genau.
Was wirklich gemacht wird,
was ein gutes Beispiel ist
und aktuell auch eingesetzt wird:
Dass man Viren oder Teile von Viren
in der Krebstherapie benutzt.
Das funktioniert so,
die Viren werden ausgestattet
mit einer Erbinformation,
z.B. von speziellen
Oberflächenrezeptoren.
Die wird über Viren
in die Zelle gebracht.
Die Zelle macht dann
diesen Oberflächenrezeptor
und kann Tumorzellen besser erkennen
und abtöten.
Das klingt gut.
Aber ist etwas,
was Umbreall nicht machen würde.
Die verfolgen böse Zwecke.
"Ich schlage vor,
wir beenden die Welt.
Aber zu unseren Konditionen.
Eine orchestrierte Apokalypse.
Eine, die die Welt
und ihre Bevölkerung vernichtet.
Aber ihre Infrastruktur
und Ressourcen bleiben unversehrt.
Es ist schon einmal geschehen.
Mit großem Erfolg."
Wenn die weiter
an dem Plan arbeiten wollen
und das Virus
nicht modifizieren können,
könnten die es
komplett zusammen basteln?
Ja, das ist sicher möglich
Viren herzustellen,
wenn man die Abfolge
der Erbsubstanz kennt.
Wenn man weiß,
welche Basen dabei sind,
kann man die komplette
Erbinformation herstellen.
Mit dieser Erbinformation stellt
die Zelle ein infektiöses Virus her.
Ich schau das Ursprungsvirus an
und baue es im Labor nach?
Würde es gehen,
dass ich ein Virus
nach meinem Geschmack
aus verschiedenen zusammenstelle?
Um z.B. ein besonders
gefährliches zu erhalten?
Das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Viren entstehen
aus einem evolutionären Prozess.
Man kann sich nicht bedienen
und wie in einem Baukasten
zusammenbauen.
Man kann nicht zusammenpacken,
was einem gefällt.
Ein schönes Beispiel
ist das Grippevirus.
Das hat spezielle Voraussetzungen.
Da liegt die Erbinformation
in Teilen vor.
Wenn 2 verschiedene Grippestämme
einen Wirt infiziert haben,
können verschiedene Grippestämme
Informationen austauschen.
Da gibt es ein neues Virus
mit anderen Erbinformationen.
Das ist in der Natur der Sonderfall.
Wie sich das Umbrella vorstellt:
Blutegel-DNA und Zombieeigenschaften,
das funktioniert nicht?
Nein, das funktioniert nicht.
Man muss
den eigenen Schutz bedenken.
Ich muss mich schützen,
wenn ich mit Viren arbeite,
oder herstellen möchte.
Das ist in Dtl. nicht einfach.
Das ist
unter behördlicher Überwachung.
Ich muss das Projekt anmelden.
Dann wird es begutachtet.
Es wird kategorisiert
in verschiedene Sicherheitsstufen.
Es gibt 4 Stufen, 1-4.
Bei unserem Institut
haben wir hauptsächlich 2-3.
Das sind Viren,
die ein geringes Risiko darstellen.
Bei 3 habe ich ein hohes Risiko
mich zu infizieren.
Auch einen schwereren Verlauf.
4 bedeutet,
dass es mir nicht gut geht.
Das ist so etwas
wie Ebola oder Marburg.
Das ist aber gut,
dass es
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen gibt.
Das müssen wir dem
Resident-Evil-Spiel zugute halten.
Wir sehen dort
die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen.
Da hat Umbrella sich etwas
aus der Realität abgeschaut.
Was ihr bei
dem Resident-Evil-Spiel seht,
die Infizierten
entwickeln Mutationen.
Hier wächst dem Charakter
ein riesiges Auge auf der Schulter.
Hier krabbeln mutierte Menschen
mit freigelegten Gehirn rum.
Das ist super abgefahren.
Gibt es bei uns etwas,
was in die Richtung geht?
Können Viren Mutationen auslösen?
Ja, das können sie.
Sie können dazu führen,
dass etwas wächst.
Ein Beispiel sind Papillom-Viren.
Das sind Warzen.
Das ist auch eklig.
Da wuchert unkontrolliert
ein bisschen Haut.
Es gibt einige Vertreter davon.
Einige Vertreter davon
lösen Krebs aus.
Sie tragen zur Krebsentstehung bei.
Wenn man mit denen
eine Weile infiziert ist,
kann man nach Jahren einen
Gebärmutterhalskrebs entwickeln.
Aber das geht
nicht so schnell wie in dem Film,
dass man nach einer Infektion
ein Auge auf der Schulter hat.
Das kreuzt die Pläne von Umbrella.
Sie wollen das
zu einer Biowaffen machen.
Sie brauchen
die 100-prozentige Zuverlässigkeit,
dass die Mutation sofort kommt.
Sie möchten auch,
dass es 100% ansteckend ist.
Ist das realistisch?
Nein, das ist nicht realistisch.
Die wenigsten Viren
haben 100% Ansteckung.
Man kommt in den Bereich von 95-98%.
100% ist unwahrscheinlich.
Das Immunsystem
arbeitet immer dagegen.
Das bedeutet,
wenn man sich infiziert,
wird das Immunsystem kämpfen.
Beim 1. Kontakt dauert es etwas
bis Antikörper gebildet werden.
Aber bei der 2. Infektion,
der Reinfektion,
geht es viel schneller.
Ein Auge auf der Schulter
und 100% Ansteckung
bekommen wir nicht hin.
Wie weit kann man Viren
im Labor beeinflussen?
Zum Beispiel
die “Gain-of-function-Methode“.
Da wird das Virus mit
besonderen Features ausgestattet.
Man versucht, der natürlichen
Mutation etwas vorzugreifen.
Ein Beispiel ist die Vogelgrippe.
Die Vogelgrippe infiziert Vögel,
keine Menschen oder Säugetiere.
Wenn man ein Vogelgrippe-Virus
mit Features ausstattet,
dass es Säugetiere infizieren kann,
kann sie diese infizieren.
Das wurde gemacht.
Frettchen wurden infiziert.
Es wurde selektiert,
dass die Viren rauskommen.
Man schaute,
ob ein infiziertes Frettchen
die anderen anstecken kann.
Man sah, dass sich
von 4 Frettchen 3 ansteckten.
Bei Tierversuche muss man nachfragen,
warum wird das gemacht?
Warum müssen wir wissen,
wie gefährlich ein Virus sein könnte?
Worauf zielt das Experiment ab?
Es ging darum,
was das nächste Pandemieereignis
werden könnte.
Man versucht
den Events vorzugreifen.
In dem man das mit der “Gain-of-
function-Methode“ zu simuliert.
Man möchte Impfstoffe
und Therapeutika entwickeln.
Könnte man Gain of Function
für "böse Zwecke" ausnutzen?
Hätte die Umbrella Coperation
die Möglichkeit,
das durchlaufen zu lassen?
Bis sich
die Gefährlichkeit potenziert?
Man kann schwer voraussagen,
in welche Richtung
ein Virus mutiert.
Das ist ein Problem.
Wenn man das gezielt beeinflusst,
hat man am Anfang Eigenschaften,
die das Virus hat.
Die man gerne haben möchte.
Wenn sich das Virus vermehrt,
mit der natürlichen Mutationsrate
und der hohen Ansteckung,
kann es sich schnell verändern.
Es kann Eigenschaften verlieren.
Es bekommt neue dazu.
Das ist schwer zu beeinflussen.
Wir können es nicht
wie ein Auto konfigurieren?
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Du hast gesagt,
der Prozess wird reguliert
und überwacht.
Man muss Anträge stellen,
bevor man ran darf.
Alle genetischen Modifikationen
sind behördlich überwacht.
Es müssen Anträge gestellt werden.
Es wird geschaut,
ob das entsprechende Labor da ist.
Darf man das machen,
hat man die Ausbildung dazu?
Man muss sagen,
was in dem Projekt gemacht wird.
Wenn ich bei der Behörde sage:
Ich möchte ein möglichst
tödliches Virus herstellen,
wird die Behörde sagen "Nein".
Vielen Dank
für die ganzen Erklärungen,
es war spannend.
Danke geht auch an Bruga.
Er hat uns
mit den Resident-Evil-Facts versorgt.
Flitzt doch zu seinem Kanal
und lasst gruselig Grüße da.
Schreibt uns gern,
wie euch diese Folge gefallen hat.
Vergesst bitte nicht diesen Kanal ...
... zu abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann können wir
uns bald wiedersehen.
Wir bereiten uns
auf sämtliche Szenarien vor.
Bis bald.
Fast so gut wie das Zombieelixier,
ist das Video von Bruga.
Wenn ihr mehr Bock auf Action habt,
findet ihr unten die Playlist.
Copyright MDR 2022